This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. There are so many small delights that people have found themselves longing for during this past year. The sudden hush in a movie theater as the lights go down. The roar of an airplane's engines as it accelerates down a runway bound for a new destination. The happy buzz of conversation and laughter in a crowded restaurant. Another tiny pleasure that has become more rare during the pandemic. The unexpected moments that we call coincidences. Staying at home has meant fewer opportunities for chance encounters,
这里是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在过去的一年里，人们发现自己渴望着许多小小的快乐。电影院灯光熄灭时那突然的寂静。飞机引擎在跑道上加速准备前往新目的地时的轰鸣。拥挤的餐厅里那令人愉悦的交谈声和笑声。疫情期间变得更加稀缺的另一种小确幸，就是我们称之为巧合的那些意外时刻。待在家里意味着偶遇的机会减少了，
like running into a neighbor on a vacation, or discovering during a chat at the water cooler that you share the same birthday as a coworker. As the pandemic is brought on the control in some parts of the world and people start to move about, we are more likely to experience coincidences. And that made us think about an episode a couple of years ago when two different listeners called into Hidden Brain. So I was a student at the University of Rhode Island and we were in this writing class. This is Amanda Birch. She told us she was chatting with the teacher of her writing class. The teacher mentioned that she lived in a small town in Vermont. The same small town it turned out where Amanda's mother had
比如在度假时偶遇邻居，或者在茶水间聊天时发现你和同事是同一天生日。随着疫情在世界某些地区得到控制，人们开始走动，我们更有可能经历巧合。这让我们想起了几年前的一期节目，当时有两位不同的听众打进《Hidden Brain》。我当时是罗德岛大学的学生，我们在一门写作课上。这是阿曼达·伯奇。她告诉我们，她当时正在和写作课的老师聊天。老师提到她住在佛蒙特州的一个小镇。结果发现，那个小镇正是阿曼达母亲
grown up. The teacher asked Amanda what her mother's maiden name was. Amanda told her, If she just kind of drops her pen and she goes, you're not going to believe this, but I live in the house where your mother grew up. The other listener who called us was Sarah Toporov. She called us on a scratchy phone line from Paris. Sarah's an American, but was living in France. One time, she was at a house party and someone there told her
长大的地方。老师问阿曼达她母亲的娘家姓什么。阿曼达告诉她，老师当时手里的笔掉在了地上，她说，你肯定不相信，但我住的房子就是你母亲长大的那栋。另一位打进电话的听众是莎拉·托波罗夫。她是从巴黎打来的，电话线路沙沙作响。莎拉是美国人，但当时住在法国。有一次，她在参加一个家庭聚会时，有人告诉她
there was another American in the room. So she went over to say hello. They started talking and... So it turns out that this girl that I met at this house party in Paris grew up in the exact same house in Piquiton, New York as my father. What are the odds? Just by chance two listeners on different continents calling in with such similar stories. This week on Hidden Brain we explore the mathematics of coincidences. That particular kind of coincidence, meeting an acquaintance or somebody you're familiar with, in a very strange place, perhaps 80% of all the coincidences I've heard, fold into
房间里还有另一位美国人。于是她走过去打招呼。他们开始交谈，结果发现……原来我在巴黎这个聚会上遇到的这个女孩，和我父亲在纽约皮基顿住的是同一栋房子。这概率得有多小？仅仅是巧合，两位身处不同大洲的听众打来电话，讲述着如此相似的故事。本周在《Hidden Brain》中，我们将探索巧合的数学原理。那种特定的巧合，即在非常奇怪的地方遇到熟人或你认识的人，我听到的巧合中大约80%都属于
that category. And we ask why these little moments feel so psychologically significant. Whenever you see something that you can't explain the natural human instinct is to try to understand it, but that can also mean that sometimes we overexplain things. We're starting today with a story about Whisper. And just so you can understand this coincidence story, we're going to first explain what Whisper is and how it works. Whisper is an app that allows users to connect anonymously online.
这一类。我们想探讨为什么这些小瞬间在心理上感觉如此重要。每当你看到无法解释的事情时，人类的本能就是试图去理解它，但这有时也意味着我们过度解读了事物。今天我们从一个关于Whisper的故事开始。为了让你理解这个巧合故事，我们先解释一下Whisper是什么以及它是如何运作的。Whisper是一个允许用户在线匿名交流的应用程序。
They can post messages or secrets. These are called Whisper's and strangers can respond with their own Whisper's. We've asked a few producers to read out some of these whispers. I'm secretly planning my wedding on Pinterest. I'm working on hotel, getting blankets. Can you watch the last? I make food, I do a tribal dance in front of the microwave. I've been faking a British accent ever since I got to college three years ago.
他们可以发布消息或秘密。这些被称为“Whisper”（耳语），陌生人可以用他们自己的“Whisper”来回应。我们请了几位制作人读出其中的一些耳语。我正在Pinterest上秘密筹划我的婚礼。我正在研究酒店，准备毯子。你能看最后那个吗？我做饭时，会在微波炉前跳一段部落舞。自从三年前上大学以来，我就一直在假装有英国口音。
The messages are short about the length of a tweet and they range from the silly, to the very serious. Some months ago the folks at Whisper got in touch to tell us a story about an interesting coincidence that happened on their site. Lauren Hudson is 27, and she turned to Whisper at one of the darkest moments of her life. I was in a really bad relationship. There was a lot of domestic violence involved, and I didn't really know what to do or how to reach out to people or how to talk about it. So I used the app to connect with other women and to kind of vent and like find empowerment
这些消息很短，大约和推文长度相当，内容从愚蠢的到非常严肃的都有。几个月前，Whisper的工作人员联系我们，讲述了发生在他们网站上的一个有趣的巧合。劳伦·哈德森今年27岁，她在人生最黑暗的时刻转向了Whisper。我当时处于一段非常糟糕的关系中。涉及很多家庭暴力，我真的不知道该怎么办，也不知道如何向别人求助或谈论这件事。所以我用这个应用程序与其他女性联系，发泄情绪并寻找力量，
to get away from the person that I was with. Lauren was having trouble opening up about what was happening with her friends and family. I think I was scared to be completely honest. I think I had a lot of fear and I didn't want any police involved. I didn't want it to turn into this whole thing. But on Whisper she could be anonymous. She could seek support without all the immediate consequences. It was there in one of these threads that she started talking to a man. Lauren was touched by how much compassion he seemed to have for her, the complete stranger.
从而离开我当时在一起的那个人。劳伦很难向朋友和家人敞开心扉谈论发生的事情。我想我害怕完全诚实。我想我有很多恐惧，我不想让警察介入。我不想让事情闹大。但在Whisper上，她可以匿名。她可以在没有直接后果的情况下寻求支持。正是在这些帖子中，她开始与一名男子交谈。劳伦被这个完全陌生的人对她表现出的同情心所打动。
It was almost as if he genuinely wanted to know how I was. Even though he didn't know who I was, and he knew that it was anonymous, and who knows who he's talking to, he's just genuinely wanted to know if I was okay. He was in a town nearby, another coincidence perhaps, and they started exchanging messages. They connected immediately, decided to meet in person. We got together and we went to Applebee's and we sat and we talked for like, I think it was like almost two hours that we just sat and talked. They became more and more inseparable. Lauren ended her unhealthy relationship
他似乎真的想知道我过得怎么样，这让我很感动。尽管他不知道我是谁，他也知道这是匿名的，谁知道他在和谁说话，但他只是真诚地想知道我是否还好。他在附近的一个镇上，这也许是另一个巧合，他们开始交换信息。他们立刻产生了共鸣，决定亲自见面。我们聚在一起去了Applebee's，坐下来聊了大概两个小时，我们只是坐着聊天。他们变得越来越形影不离。劳伦结束了她那段不健康的关系，
and started dating this guy from Whisperr, Eric. And everything was going great. But Lauren was a little nervous about meeting Eric's family. Eric had brought Lauren home to have dinner with them, and the whole time she was anxious. Like my palms were sweating and I felt like really hot. You know, so I didn't know if like, And the whole time, she was anxious. When I first met her, the first couple times that we hung out and stuff, I knew that there was a little bit of a distance there and I knew that every time I went over to, you know, hang out with Eric and his family, that those walls would slowly break down. But Lauren was impatient.
开始和这个来自Whisper的家伙埃里克约会。一切都很顺利。但劳伦对见埃里克的家人感到有点紧张。埃里克带劳伦回家和他们一起吃晚饭，她一直很焦虑。我的手心在出汗，我觉得很热。你知道，所以我不知道是否……她一直很焦虑。我第一次见到她时，我们在一起待的前几次，我知道她有一点距离感，我知道每次我去埃里克家和他家人待在一起时，那些隔阂会慢慢打破。但劳伦很心急。
She and Eric were getting engaged. Lauren understood Amanda's attitude. She felt the same toward the girls her younger brother would bring home. Maybe I'll see them next week, you know, or maybe I'll never see them again. You know what I mean? So that was kind of like what I had in my head. I was like well I hope that you know I'm thinking I hope that they know that I'm not going anywhere. Lauren wasn't going anywhere. She and Eric were getting engaged. Eric in fact had a flair for the romantic, bringing her roses, comforting her with her favorite movie after a tough day, and he would tell his family about all this. So why couldn't Lauren break through with Amanda?
她和埃里克要订婚了。劳伦理解阿曼达的态度。她对她弟弟带回家的女孩也有同样的感觉。也许我下周会见到她们，你知道，或者也许我再也见不到她们了。你明白我的意思吗？所以这大概就是我脑子里想的。我想，好吧，我希望她们知道我哪儿也不会去。劳伦哪儿也不会去。她和埃里克要订婚了。事实上，埃里克很有浪漫情怀，给她送玫瑰，在劳伦度过艰难的一天后用她最喜欢的电影安慰她，他会告诉家人所有这些事。那么为什么劳伦不能和阿曼达建立联系呢？
All this time, Lauren was still on whisper. Now I use it instead of me looking for help, I use it to help others. That's my way of giving back because the whisper community helped me when I needed them. One day, she started exchanging messages with a woman who was going through a very painful break up. I sent a big message, basically saying that it's okay, everyone goes to heartaches and there will be many more people out there. As a way to offer encouragement, Lauren told the woman about her own happy relationship.
一直以来，劳伦仍然在使用Whisper。现在我用它不是为了寻求帮助，而是为了帮助别人。这是我回馈社会的方式，因为当我需要的时候，Whisper社区帮助了我。有一天，她开始与一位正在经历痛苦分手的女性交换信息。我发了一条很长的信息，基本上说没关系，每个人都会经历心碎，外面还会有很多人。为了鼓励对方，劳伦告诉了那位女性她自己幸福的关系。
The woman asked Lauren about the nicest thing her fiancee had done for her. Lauren told her about the day Eric surprised her with her favorite movie. On my birthday, I had a really bad day at work. It was like one of those days where you wake up and just from the moment you put your feet on the floor, everything goes wrong. So I didn't want to see him that day. I was just miserable. I just wanted to be home. Like I was just like I just want to go to bed. And he surprised me with these beautiful flowers, these roses, and he had the notebook, which is my favorite like
那位女性问劳伦她未婚夫为她做过的最贴心的事情是什么。劳伦告诉了她埃里克给她惊喜，放她最喜欢电影的那一天。在我生日那天，我在工作中度过了非常糟糕的一天。就像那种你一醒来，从你脚落地的那一刻起，一切都不对劲的日子。所以我那天不想见他。我只是很痛苦。我只想待在家里。我当时就想，我只想上床睡觉。但他给了我惊喜，送了这些漂亮的花，这些玫瑰，还有《恋恋笔记本》，这是我最喜欢的……
sappy love story of all time. Lauren finished telling her story and waited for a reply. Her first response after I sent that story to her, she's like, Lauren. Like, she, Lauren, I was like, how do you know my name? You know, because it's all anonymous and she's like, this is Amanda. Amanda, Eric's sister, the very person, she'd been trying so desperately to connect with in real life. Lauren says this coincidence changed her whole relationship with Amanda. Connecting randomly online and revealing intimate details about themselves, made the two women feel closer.
有史以来最感人的爱情故事。劳伦讲完了她的故事，等待回复。在我发完那个故事后，她的第一反应是，劳伦。她，劳伦，我当时想，你怎么知道我的名字？你知道，因为这一切都是匿名的，她说，我是阿曼达。阿曼达，埃里克的妹妹，正是她一直拼命想在现实生活中建立联系的那个人。劳伦说，这个巧合改变了她和阿曼达的整个关系。在网上随机联系并透露彼此的私密细节，让这两个女人感觉更亲近了。
Many of us have experienced these kinds of coincidences. You bump into your kindergarten friend, you'll first stay in college, or you meet someone at a party and discover she lives in your dad's childhood home in Prokipsi. When these kinds of coincidences happen in our lives, they feel like magic. But as any mathematician will tell you,
我们许多人都经历过这类巧合。你在大学里偶遇幼儿园的朋友，或者你在聚会上遇到一个人，发现她住的是你父亲在波基普西的童年故居。当这类巧合发生在我们的生活中时，它们感觉就像魔法。但正如任何数学家会告诉你的那样，
things that feel unusual or even impossible are actually fairly common. Mathematician Joseph Meuser knows this, but he was reluctant to write a book that would dispel the magic. Coincidences are wonderful stories. I don't want to blow the stories in favor of the mathematics because, you know, I was hitting a nerve on coincidences.
感觉不寻常甚至不可能的事情实际上相当普遍。数学家约瑟夫·马泽尔知道这一点，但他不愿写一本会消除这种魔力的书。巧合是美妙的故事。我不想为了数学而破坏这些故事，因为，你知道，我触及了巧合的痛点。
In the end though, Joseph did write his book. It's called Fluk, the math and myth of coincidence. It's full of stories of people who find themselves experiencing things that feel so unlikely. But Joseph Mauser says, if you study this for a while, the coincidences start to fall into certain categories. And the stories we heard from our two listeners, as well as Lauren's story about meeting her soon-to-be sister-in-law in whisper, are all basically the same type of coincidence, which in itself is not a coincidence.
不过最终，约瑟夫还是写了他的书。书名是《Fluke：巧合的数学与神话》。书中充满了人们经历那些感觉极不可能发生的事情的故事。但约瑟夫·马泽尔说，如果你研究一段时间，巧合就会开始归入某些类别。我们从两位听众那里听到的故事，以及劳伦关于在Whisper上遇到她未来的小姑子的故事，本质上都是同一种巧合，这本身并不是巧合。
If you categorize these coincidences to, let's say, ten different categories, that particular kind of coincidence, meeting an acquaintance or somebody you're familiar with, in a very strange place, I would say perhaps 80% of all the coincidence is as I've heard, fold into that category. Joseph Mauser says, the reason these coincidences feel extraordinary, but actually are not so extraordinary, is because of a common misconception about the number of people we think we actually know. People think that their dress book is essentially the people they know, and it turns out that any particular dress book is about 1% of the people
如果你把这些巧合归类为，比如说，十个不同的类别，那种特定的巧合，即在非常奇怪的地方遇到熟人或你认识的人，我会说我听到的所有巧合中大约80%都属于这一类。约瑟夫·马泽尔说，这些巧合之所以感觉非凡，但实际上并非如此非凡，是因为人们对我们认为自己真正认识的人数存在普遍误解。人们认为他们的通讯录基本上就是他们认识的人，但事实证明，任何特定的通讯录大约只占他们
they actually know in some way, in other words a neighbor, some of the bump into in the street, but the dress book is about 1% of the people they know. As a result, the odds of bumping into someone you know are much greater than you think, because you know many more people than you think. Sometimes math can help us understand the magic. Magic like winning the lottery, not just once, but several times. That's what happened to a woman named Joan Ginter. 1993 I think it was, she won $5.4 million in Texas Lotto. 13 years later, she won again
以某种方式认识的人的1%，换句话说，邻居，你在街上偶遇的人，但通讯录大约只占他们认识的人的1%。因此，偶遇熟人的概率比你想象的要大得多，因为你认识的人比你想象的要多得多。有时数学可以帮助我们理解魔力。像中彩票这样的魔力，不仅是一次，而是好几次。这就是一位名叫琼·金特尔的女性身上发生的事情。我想是1993年，她赢得了德克萨斯彩票的540万美元。13年后，她又赢了
$2 million. And then a few years after that, she won $3 million. And then in 2010, she won $10 million. What are the odds of one person winning the lottery four times? Yeah, the odds are, I think somebody made a calculation and I did too, that the odds are about 18 septillion to one against it happening. 18 septillion to one. That's incomprehensible. For those who are not mathematicians, a septillion is one followed by 24 zeros. But Joseph Maeser says, we're actually asking the wrong question.
200万美元。几年后，她又赢了300万美元。然后在2010年，她赢了1000万美元。一个人四次中彩票的概率是多少？是的，概率是，我想有人做过计算，我也做过，概率大约是18万亿亿分之一。18万亿亿分之一。这简直不可思议。对于非数学家来说，万亿亿（septillion）是1后面跟着24个零。但约瑟夫·马泽尔说，我们实际上问错了问题。
Think about it this way. If I buy a lottery ticket and I ask the question, what are the odds that I will win? My odds are very small. But if I ask, what are the odds that anyone will win the lottery? In a country of hundreds of millions of people, the odds are actually much higher. So if you ask the question slightly differently, not what are the odds that Joan Ginter will win the lottery four times, but what are the odds that anyone will win four times? You get a very different answer.
换个角度想。如果我买了一张彩票，问中奖的概率是多少？我的概率非常小。但如果我问，任何人中彩票的概率是多少？在一个拥有数亿人口的国家，概率实际上要高得多。所以如果你稍微换个问法，不是问琼·金特尔四次中彩票的概率是多少，而是问任何人四次中奖的概率是多少？你会得到一个非常不同的答案。
I think I calculated at one point about 5 million to one, which is not anywhere near the Septilions. It's about 5 million to one. And that takes into account the fact that we have thousands of lotteries in the world. I mean, there are many lotteries and many of them are big time lotteries. So, 5 million to one, still unlikely, but not incomprehensible. What makes it even more comprehensible is the fact that most lottery winners don't stop gambling when they win. And you do find that almost everybody who does win a lottery fairly big time
我想我曾经计算过大约500万分之一，这与万亿亿相去甚远。大约是500万分之一。这考虑到了世界上有成千上万种彩票的事实。我的意思是，有很多彩票，其中许多是大额彩票。所以，500万分之一，虽然不太可能，但并非不可理解。让它更可理解的事实是，大多数彩票中奖者在赢钱后并不会停止赌博。你会发现几乎所有赢得大奖的人
spends all that money or much of that money in trying to win again. Joseph Maysor says this might have been the case with John Ginter. You win $5.4 million, you have a money to play with, you have house money. So you're taking the house money to bet again and her odds of winning a second time are better than most people because she's got the money to play with. She wins the second time, then she's playing with more money, and you can see the between the first winning and the second winning, it was 13 years, between the second winning and the third, it was only two years, and between the winning and the second winning, it was 13 years, between the second winning and the third, it was only two years, and between the third and the fourth was only two years as well.
都会把所有的钱或大部分钱花在试图再次中奖上。约瑟夫·马泽尔说，琼·金特尔的情况可能就是这样。你赢了540万美元，你有钱可以玩，你有“庄家的钱”。所以你拿着庄家的钱再次下注，她第二次中奖的概率比大多数人都要高，因为她有钱可以玩。她第二次赢了，然后她拿着更多的钱玩，你可以看到第一次中奖和第二次中奖之间是13年，第二次中奖和第三次之间只有两年，第三次和第四次之间也只有两年。
So Joseph Mauser can wrap his head around what happened to Joan Gynther, but there are some coincidences that just defy mathematical interpretation. Joseph told me one of his favorite stories about a 19th century French poet Emil de Champ. Emil de Champ, as a teenager, he meets a man by the name of a strange name, Monsieur de Fortique-Bou. He turns out to be an immigrant from England and a faute bou introduces him to a plum pudding. It's a very English dish that's almost unheard of in France. Ten years go by and Dixamp is passing a restaurant in Paris. There's a sign on the window saying that they have plum pudding on their menu.
所以约瑟夫·马泽尔可以理解琼·金特尔身上发生的事情，但有些巧合确实违背了数学解释。约瑟夫给我讲了他最喜欢的故事之一，关于19世纪法国诗人埃米尔·德尚。德尚十几岁时，遇到一个名字很奇怪的人，德·福蒂格-布先生。他原来是从英国来的移民，福蒂格-布向他介绍了李子布丁。这是一种非常英式的菜肴，在法国几乎闻所未闻。十年过去了，德尚路过巴黎的一家餐厅。窗户上的招牌写着他们的菜单上有李子布丁。
But when Dixamp goes inside, he stole the last of the plum pudding was just sold to a gentleman sitting in the back. The waiter calls out loud. Mr. Disham, would you be willing to share your plum pudding with this gentleman? Year has passed. Disham is now at a dinner party with some friends. The host announces an unusual dessert will be served, plum pudding. And the shamp jokes that one of the guests to arrive must be Mr. DeFotigu. Well, as soon the doorbell rings, Mr. DeFotigu is announced.
但当德尚进去时，最后一份李子布丁刚刚卖给坐在后面的一位绅士。服务员大声喊道。德尚先生，您愿意和这位绅士分享您的李子布丁吗？又一年过去了。德尚现在正在和朋友们参加晚宴。主人宣布将上一道不寻常的甜点，李子布丁。德尚开玩笑说，到场的客人中一定有德·福蒂格先生。好吧，门铃一响，德·福蒂格先生的名字就被宣布了。
And he enters, he's an old man by now, but the shent recognizes him, Mr. Edifurton, who looks around and realizes that he's in the wrong apartment. He was invited to a dinner, but not in that apartment. I love that because it's a triple coincidence. And it has a beautiful story element with it. I mean, that's so magnificent. And that's why that's the kind of coincidence I love to hear. Joseph Mazar, Professor of Mathematics and author of Fluke,
他进来了，现在已经是一位老人了，但德尚认出了他，德·福蒂格先生环顾四周，意识到他走错了公寓。他被邀请参加晚宴，但不是在那间公寓。我喜欢这个故事，因为它是一个三重巧合。而且它有一个美丽的叙事元素。我的意思是，这太壮观了。这就是我喜欢听的那种巧合。约瑟夫·马泽尔，数学教授，《Fluke：巧合的数学与神话》的作者。
the Math and Myth of Coincidence. When we come back, we're going to look at what coincidences reveal about the mind. In particular, I'm fascinated by something I've observed in my own life. When I experience a coincidence, it invariably feels more meaningful to me than it does to others. Stay with us. Welcome back to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vidantam. I'm fascinated by coincidences and
回来后，我们将看看巧合揭示了关于思维的什么。特别是，我对自己生活中观察到的一些事情很着迷。当我经历巧合时，它对我来说总是比对其他人更有意义。请继续收听。欢迎回到《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我对巧合很着迷，
could listen for hours to stories about them. But what is it that so fascinates us about these moments in life? At the University of Chicago, psychologists Nick Epley thinks he might have one answer. He's the author of the book, Mindwise. To understand how Epley thinks about coincidences, I need to take a moment and explain his broader work to you first. Epley's book examines how we read the mental states and intentions of other people. This is a remarkably useful skill, but we sometimes misapply it. We sometimes attribute intentionality to things that aren't even living, especially
可以花几个小时听关于它们的故事。但到底是什么让我们对生活中的这些时刻如此着迷？在芝加哥大学，心理学家尼克·埃普利认为他可能有一个答案。他是《Mindwise》一书的作者。要理解埃普利如何看待巧合，我需要花点时间先向你解释他的更广泛的工作。埃普利的书研究了我们如何解读他人的心理状态和意图。这是一项非常实用的技能，但我们有时会误用它。我们有时会将意图归因于甚至没有生命的东西，特别是
when they're out of the ordinary. For example, we don't personify a sunny day, but we give hurricanes a name. Katrina, Sandy, Andrew. After Hurricane Katrina, the mayor of New Orleans said, God must be mad at America. This is a new. For centuries, people have ascribed intentionality to natural forces. We think storms, droughts, and earthquakes must have a mind of their own. This general tendency to explain behaviors in terms of purpose or intent or meaning is often quite a successful thing to do. Turns out we live with other people who do have intentions and goals and foresight and planning and meaning behind their actions. And so by and large,
当它们不同寻常时。例如，我们不会将晴天人格化，但我们会给飓风命名。卡特里娜、桑迪、安德鲁。卡特里娜飓风过后，新奥尔良市长说，上帝一定是在对美国发火。这并不新鲜。几个世纪以来，人们一直将意图归因于自然力量。我们认为风暴、干旱和地震一定有自己的思想。这种将行为解释为目的、意图或意义的普遍倾向通常是非常成功的。事实证明，我们确实与拥有意图、目标、远见、计划和行动背后意义的其他人生活在一起。所以总的来说，
that tendency to make those kinds of attributions to other people is a good way to learn about each other, is a good way to explain why other people did something in the past, to predict how they're likely to behave in the future. But the problem with any kind of good tool is that sometimes we use it a little too much. And that's what happens in these cases, where you're trying to explain the behavior of something that doesn't really have a sensible explanation for it. Some random events, some chance occurrence, some physical anomaly, some weather pattern that crops up that might not in fact have a mind behind it.
那种对他人进行此类归因的倾向是了解彼此的好方法，是解释为什么别人在过去做了某事，以及预测他们未来可能如何表现的好方法。但任何好工具的问题在于，有时我们使用得有点过头了。这就是在这些情况下发生的事情，你试图解释某种并没有合理解释的事物的行为。一些随机事件，一些偶然发生的事情，一些物理异常，一些突然出现的可能并没有背后思想的天气模式。
This is why we are fascinated by robots that move in unpredictable ways. What we found was that when people were given a description of an object that made it sound unpredictable, like you couldn't anticipate its actions, that's when people described it or reported that it had more mental states. They were more willing to say that the object has a mind of its own, that it has intentions, for instance. And I don't think this is totally counterintuitive that is a mind.
这就是为什么我们对以不可预测方式移动的机器人着迷。我们发现，当人们得到一个描述，使物体听起来不可预测时，比如你无法预料它的行动，那时人们就会描述或报告它具有更多的心理状态。他们更愿意说这个物体有自己的思想，例如，它有意图。我不认为这完全违反直觉，这就是思想。
If you see, for instance, a billiard ball sitting on a table, another ball comes along and hits it, and that ball rolls off in the predicted direction. Well, you don't need anything to explain that, but if you've got a ball sitting on a table, and it suddenly starts rolling around randomly, well, then you've got something to explain. And in these cases, sometimes people look to the inside of an agent, give it a mind, maybe the ball is possessed.
例如，如果你看到一个台球放在桌子上，另一个球过来撞击它，那个球以预期的方向滚走。好吧，你不需要任何东西来解释这一点，但如果你有一个球放在桌子上，它突然开始随机滚动，好吧，那你就有东西要解释了。在这些情况下，有时人们会看向代理的内部，赋予它思想，也许球被附身了。
Maybe there's a demon controlling it, moving it around the table. Sometimes people attribute a mind to something when it's not there, but they do that as an effort to explain what's going on in this autonomous, in this autonomous agent. And they're more likely to do that when an agent behaves somewhat unpredictably. I was over at a friend's house and my friend has a wonderful pool and he had set this underwater room bar for the lack of a better term to clean the bottom of the pool. So it sort of rolls around the bottom of the pool. And it goes in this completely random fashion, right?
也许有一个恶魔在控制它，在桌子上移动它。有时人们在某物不存在思想时也会赋予它思想，但他们这样做是为了努力解释这个自主代理中正在发生的事情。当代理表现得有些不可预测时，他们更有可能这样做。我当时在我朋友家，我朋友有一个很棒的游泳池，他设置了这个水下清洁机器人（为了缺乏更好的术语）来清洁池底。所以它在池底滚动。它以完全随机的方式运行，对吧？
So it just runs for a couple of hours. It's cleaning the bottom of the pool. And I found myself fascinated just watching it because the fact that you can't predict what it's going to do next makes it just more interesting and more alive in a way than something that moves in a very predictable fashion. Absolutely. Something that moves robotically, very predictably, that is just a mindless machine, but when your roomba is going around randomly, well, now it wants to go over there a little bit. Now it wants to move over here.
所以它只是运行了几个小时。它在清洁池底。我发现自己只是看着它就着迷了，因为你无法预测它接下来会做什么的事实，使它比以非常可预测方式移动的东西更有趣，在某种程度上更生动。绝对是这样。以机器人方式、非常可预测地移动的东西，那只是一个无脑的机器，但当你的Roomba随机移动时，好吧，现在它想去那边一点。现在它想移到这里。
Now it realizes it didn't clean that side of the pool over there. Things that behave randomly start to get a little sense of a mind. Now people aren't crazy. You don't think it's like your mother, right, or your spouse who's vacuuming the living room. But it starts to look just a little bit more mindful. In fact, the Rumbas are good example. People actually do name their Rumbas. You can buy outfits to dress it up. If you Google this online, you'll find all kinds of examples of people thinking of their Rumbas having perhaps a little bit more of a mind than it really does. I want to talk to you a little bit about the subject of coincidences. And I thought of
现在它意识到它没有清洁池子的那一侧。表现随机的事物开始获得一点思想感。现在人们并不疯狂。你不会认为它像你母亲，对吧，或者像在客厅吸尘的配偶。但它开始看起来确实更有思想一点。事实上，Roomba就是一个很好的例子。人们确实会给他们的Roomba命名。你可以买衣服给它打扮。如果你在网上搜索这个，你会发现各种各样的人认为他们的Roomba拥有的思想可能比它实际拥有的要多一点。我想和你谈谈巧合这个主题。我想到
you in your work because it feels to me that when something unusual happens to us, and we stop, and we say, that is weird, I was just reading this word in a book a second ago, and someone in the room around me mentions the very same word. And it makes you stop and look up just like I stop and look at that underwater room. Absolutely. That's a case where something unusual happens. It was unpredictable and you try
了你和你的工作，因为我觉得当我们身上发生不寻常的事情时，我们停下来，说，这太奇怪了，我刚才在书里读到这个词，我周围房间里的某个人提到了同一个词。这让你停下来抬头看，就像我停下来看那个水下机器人一样。绝对是这样。那是一种不寻常的事情发生的情况。它是不可预测的，你试图
to explain it. You can explain these kinds of random coincidences in lots of different ways or lots of different kinds of causal structures we might be able to put on it. But some of them involve giving it more meaning than it actually has. This is what underwater rune bars have to do with coincidences. Like a robot that does something unexpected, coincidences cry out for meaning or explanation because they're out of the ordinary. We start to seek patterns even when they aren't any. My favorite example of this in the world of psychology is actually a phenomenon
解释它。你可以用许多不同的方式或许多不同种类的因果结构来解释这些随机巧合。但其中一些涉及赋予它比实际更多的意义。这就是水下机器人与巧合的关系。就像做意想不到事情的机器人一样，巧合因为不同寻常而呼唤意义或解释。即使没有模式，我们也开始寻找模式。在心理学界，我最喜欢的例子实际上是一种现象，
first documented by my PhD advisor Tom Gillovich and the brilliant psychologist Amos Tversky. It was the illusion of the hot hand in basketball. Danny Greene again from downtown. He said six and a row going back to game two. The myth is that when shooting free throws, basketball players get on a roll. People believe that basketball players get a hot hand, and that their times when they're on and the chance of making a basket is higher after they've just made one than after they've just missed one.
首先由我的博士导师汤姆·吉洛维奇和杰出的心理学家阿莫斯·特沃斯基记录。这就是篮球中的“手感火热”错觉。丹尼·格林再次从远距离投篮。他说回到第二场比赛，他已经连续投进了六个。神话是，在罚球时，篮球运动员会进入状态。人们相信篮球运动员有“火热的手感”，并且在他们刚刚投进一个球后，投进下一个球的概率比刚刚投丢后要高。
Eplea isn't saying basketball players don't have streaks. He's saying we draw the wrong conclusion about these streaks. Let's imagine that they're a good shooter and they shoot 50% from the field. That 50% probability is gonna produce a lot more clumping. In the baskets, then people expect. People expect a coin flip, a 50% probability, to alternate a lot more than it actually does.
埃普利并不是说篮球运动员没有连胜。他是说我们对这些连胜得出了错误的结论。让我们假设他们是一个优秀的射手，投篮命中率为50%。那50%的概率会产生比人们预期的多得多的聚集。在篮筐中，人们预期抛硬币，50%的概率，会比实际情况交替出现得多得多。
And so when you see randomness out in the world, it actually looks more ordered to you than it really is. Eplea described a party trick that demonstrates this phenomenon. You can do this too. Give everyone in the party a note card and have them write down what they think 30 coin flips would look like. H, if they think it will be heads, T, if they think it will be tails.
所以当你看到世界上的随机性时，它实际上看起来比它真实的样子更有序。埃普利描述了一个演示这种现象的派对把戏。你也可以这样做。给派对上的每个人一张记事卡，让他们写下他们认为30次抛硬币会是什么样子。H，如果他们认为是正面，T，如果他们认为是反面。
You then, as master magician, leave the room and you have one person come up and actually flip a coin 30 times. That person writes down the actual sequence of coin flips on a note card and then collects all the note cards, the real and the imagined sequences, and puts them together. You the magician then come back into the room and identify the card that was the real coin flip. And the way you do this is you look for the card that has the longest runs because people's imagination
然后，作为魔术大师，你离开房间，让一个人上来实际抛30次硬币。那个人在记事卡上写下实际的抛硬币序列，然后收集所有的记事卡，真实的和想象的序列，把它们放在一起。作为魔术师的你回到房间，识别出那张真实的抛硬币卡片。你这样做的方法是寻找有最长连续运行的卡片，因为人们的想象力
doesn't presume that a 50-50 probability will produce very long runs. And so people's imagined coin flips will alternate more than the real coin flip will. And that's how you can identify the real one from the fake ones. And I think that illusion that we have, that randomness alternates, or as more chancy than it actually is, that there's less clumping, is also the thing that gives rise to these other phenomena where we see randomness in the world, and we see more predictability or intentionality than actually exists in it. When we asked our listeners to share coincidences with us, many of them wrote
并不认为50-50的概率会产生非常长的连续运行。所以人们想象的抛硬币会比真实的抛硬币交替出现得更多。这就是你如何从假的卡片中识别出真实卡片的方法。我认为我们拥有的那种错觉，即随机性会交替出现，或者比实际情况更具偶然性，即聚集更少，也是导致这些其他现象的原因，即我们在世界上看到随机性，并且看到的预测性或意图比实际存在的要多。当我们请听众与我们分享巧合时，他们中的许多人写
in with really interesting examples of things that happened to them, one thing that I was struck by is the sense that sometimes a coincidence seems more meaningful to you than it does to someone else. So for example, when I'm reading a book and I come by an unusual word and then someone in the room mentions that same word To me it feels like it's a sign of something But if I would have told you I say Nick, you know this happened to me yesterday You'd say yeah, sure that's gonna happen Once every month or so it's exactly what you would expect if you believe the laws of probability Why do you think it is that coincidence is are more meaningful to us than to other people?
信分享了发生在他们身上的非常有趣的例子，有一件事让我印象深刻，那就是有时巧合对你来说似乎比对别人更有意义。例如，当我读一本书时，我遇到了一个不寻常的词，然后房间里的某个人提到了同一个词。对我来说，这感觉像是某种迹象。但如果我告诉你，我说尼克，你知道昨天发生在我身上的事吗？你会说，是的，当然，这会发生。每个月左右一次，这正是如果你相信概率定律所期望的。你认为为什么巧合对我们来说比对其他人更有意义？
That's a really good question. I actually don't know that I've seen any research that demonstrates that phenomena, but that strikes me as a very compelling hypothesis. I think that's probably likely to be right. And I think the reason why coincidences seem very meaningful in the first place is that you're trying to explain them. You and I both thought of the word propeller at the same time. How on earth could that be that Shankar was thinking about propeller at the same time that I was? And so you're trying to explain that. You're focusing on that event that just happened to you. It has personal relevance to you.
这是一个非常好的问题。我实际上不知道我是否见过任何证明这种现象的研究，但这对我来说是一个非常有说服力的假设。我认为这很可能是对的。我认为巧合之所以首先看起来非常有意义，是因为你正在试图解释它们。你和我同时想到了“螺旋桨”这个词。尚卡尔怎么可能在我想“螺旋桨”的同时也在想它呢？所以你正在试图解释这一点。你专注于刚刚发生在你身上的那个事件。它对你有个人相关性。
That makes it impactful. But it also makes you somewhat myopic. And what we don't think about are all of the other things that any of us in the room could have thought about at the same time that might also have seemed amazing to us. We're trying to explain this one thing because it's so meaningful to us, it just happened to us. Other people are less likely to be that myopic, I think,
这使它具有影响力。但也使你有点近视。而我们没有想到的是，房间里的任何人可能同时想到的所有其他事情，这些事情对我们来说也可能看起来很神奇。我们试图解释这一件事，因为它对我们太有意义了，它刚刚发生在我们身上。其他人不太可能那么近视，我认为，
and so they would be likely to think about other things that could have happened to you, which would make it seem less amazing to them. We, of course, experienced the Sarsals here at the show, when two listeners called in with eerily similar coincidence stories. I described these two stories to Nick about women who ran into people, who turned out to live in the very same house where the women's parents had grown up. So these are not just two coincidences.
所以他们可能会想到其他可能发生在你身上的事情，这会使它在他们看来不那么神奇。我们当然在节目中经历过这些，当两位听众打进电话讲述极其相似的巧合故事时。我向尼克描述了这两个关于女性偶遇他人的故事，结果发现那些人住的房子正是这些女性的父母长大的地方。所以这不仅仅是两个巧合。
These are two coincidences. These are two coincidences that both happened to us at Hidden Brain, which seems truly extraordinary, Nick. How could that possibly be that you get these two that are exactly the same as magic as what it is, Shankar? You're magical.
这是两个巧合。这是两个都发生在《Hidden Brain》的巧合，这看起来确实非凡，尼克。怎么可能得到这两个完全一样的东西，就像魔法一样，尚卡尔？你是魔法。
That's really just all I wanted to hear you say, Nick, it's been 20 minutes to get that out of you. Yeah. Eventually we have to give into the laws of probability. There's nothing Nick can explain that, right? Nick I want to thank you for talking with us today. Yeah, thanks for having me. Nick Eppley is the author of Mindwise how we understand what others think, believe, feel,
那真的只是我想听你说的，尼克，花了20分钟才让你说出来。是的。最终我们必须屈服于概率定律。尼克对此无法解释，对吧？尼克，我想感谢你今天和我们交谈。是的，谢谢邀请我。尼克·埃普利是《Mindwise：我们如何理解他人的想法、信念、感受》的作者，
and want. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Ryan Katz, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Autumn Barnes and Andrew Chadwick. Our executive producer is Tara Boyle. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. When this episode was first released back in 2016, it was the very first one in which we recognized an unsung hero.
和需求。《Hidden Brain》由Hidden Brain Media制作。我们的制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、瑞安·卡茨、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·夸雷尔、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德威克。我们的执行制片人是塔拉·博伊尔。我是《Hidden Brain》的执行编辑。当这一集在2016年首次发布时，它是我们第一个表彰无名英雄的节目。
In the years since then, this moment at the end of our show has become an important part of what we do at Hidden Brain. Our very first unsung hero was Matilda P.R. a senior project manager at NPR. She knew everything about everything and as Hidden Brain launched into the world, she played an important role in getting it started. She was always generous with her time and generous with her knowledge. Thank you Mato. If you like this episode, please consider supporting our work. You can do so by going to support.hiddenbrain.org. I'm Shankar Vedanthan. See you next week. you you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
从那以后的几年里，我们节目结束时的这一刻已经成为我们在《Hidden Brain》所做工作的重要组成部分。我们的第一位无名英雄是NPR的高级项目经理玛蒂尔达·P.R.。她对一切都了如指掌，当《Hidden Brain》推向世界时，她在启动过程中发挥了重要作用。她总是慷慨地贡献自己的时间和知识。谢谢你，玛托。如果你喜欢这一集，请考虑支持我们的工作。你可以通过访问support.hiddenbrain.org来做到这一点。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。下周见。你你这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。